what reductionism allows you to do is to
take a complex problem and focus on one
component of it and try to understand it
in some detail and sometimes you can
just do it by focusing on one component
all the times it requires selecting a
particular biological system if you're
working in biology in which that
component is prominent or easy to study
and that allows you to study in depth
the problem that would be hard to do if
you looked at it in all of its
complexity for me the reductionist
approach was really a very profitable
and not something that I really thought
a lot about before I originally went to
medical school with the idea of becoming
a psychoanalyst I didn't have a strong
biological background at all and then in
my senior year at medical school there
was a five-month selective period in
which you could do whatever you wanted
to and I thought that even a
psychoanalyst she knows something about
the brain so I took an elective in brain
science there were very few people doing
brain science in those days but Columbia
had an outstanding person Harry go in
first and I worked in his lab but I
worked with one of his associates Don
purpura and had absolutely spectacular
experience I mean actually doing science
is so different than reading about it
there's a central pleasure of doing the
experiments there's the front of
thinking about it coming up with a new
finding I just thought it was marvelous
and I had just the knees and I just
decided to get married and we had dinner
one night and I remember saying to her
you know I could see doing this for the
rest of my life but it's completely
unrealistic you don't have any money and
I don't have any
you know we want to have kids I should
really go into practice and she banged
in the table and she had said money is
of no significance I should tell you
sotto voce that in the subsequent 60 is
she's not repeated those words very
often but she did say them that night
and it made a big impact on me
so I decided to go ahead with signs and
when I got out of medical school which
was in 1956 physicians were being
drafted in the service for two years but
if you qualified for the National
Institute of Health that was served as
an alternative to the draft duty so he
nominated me grant fest to the NIH and
National Institute of Health and I was
selected so I spent two in fact and
spent three years there spent the next
three year doing brain biology and I
asked myself what's the central problem
and psychoanalysis and I thought memory
storage you know we all who we all
because what we learned will remember
and psychoanalysis is designed to allow
you to relive earlier experiences early
memories in a protected environment
Brenda Miller had just shown that the
hippocampus in a mammalian brain is
central for memory storage and I had
mastered in Griffiths lab how to put
electrodes into single cells this is
something you know many people can do
now but when he taught it to me the
relatively few people could do it in
fact the whole population doing brain
science was very small so my colleague
Walden Spencer my recruited to join me
on this and I were the first people in
the world to record from single cells
and hippocampus we will you fork the
people around us thought it was
fantastic you know two incompetent
people coming to the NIH and the
intellectual vom is so extraordinary it
brings them up to this higher level so
we studied these single cells does it
characterize their properties and we saw
after a while they were not dramatically
different from the other two or three
groups of cells that have been described
so clearly learning doesn't reside just
in the properties of cells should have
been obvious in the beginning
it it resides in how a behavior is
modified by learning how something
changes in the neural network and we had
no idea what the sensor information
coming into the upper campus was we
tried various things nothing worked
turns out that space is very important
it's a complex modality so I realized
what needed to take a very different
approach a reductionist approach rather
than going to the most complex example
human memory take a very simple
Pablo Thorndike just studied simple
reflex behaviors and how were they were
modified by learning so I began to look
for an animal that had simple reflex
behaviors and it was advantageous from a
nervous system point of view and that's
what led me to a pleasure it's an animal
that has only 20,000 nerve cells
compared to the hundred millions of
nerve cells in your brain
it only has 20,000 and each of them is
gigantic oh please he had the largest
nerve cells in the animal kingdom and
you can easily put an electrode into any
of these cells and be there for 24 hours
if you wanted to and the cells are
already launched they uniquely
identifiable
so you can return to the same cell in
every animal of the species so not only
that but turns out that one of the most
interesting laboratories the only two
laboratories working on it
was in Paris my wife is a Parisian
chauvinist so we went to Paris the
alternative was must say another person
was working on anjali Cavani tacky shows
Charlotte's an artist working my saying
the me said going to my say is like
going to Albany we should go to Paris so
we went to Paris really great year and I
started to work out a very simple
behavior in the animal it withdrawal
reflex like a bit through all of a hand
from a hot object and I showed it could
be modified by different forms of
learning and in each case the learning
involved a change in the strength of
synaptic connections so nerve cells
connect with each other at junctions
called synapses and I found that those
synapses are not fixed but they're
plastic and they're modified by learning
certain kinds of learning causes an
increase in strength learn fear
classical conditioning
some like habituation learning to forget
about something
please to a decrease in synaptic
strength later I found as short-term
memory and long-term memory short-term
memory is a change in functional
connections the last four minutes the
hours and long term memory is actually
an anatomical change a growth of new
synaptic connections so I really learned
a great deal about this and then in
about 1980 I started a second front that
returned to their per campus but that
time wouldn't had a much better
understanding and it turned out that the
rules there are pretty much the same
here except one is looking at more
complex behavior